[Laughter]  [Music]  but for me it's it's a it's it's a quick  thrill I mean you know it takes me a  year to get have a quick thrill with a  movie I have a lot during the year and I  have a couple highs but essentially it's  only when the movies done you're able to  look at it and say finally it's over I'm  satisfied you know with a video game I  can I can play that I can play Tempest  and in ten minutes I can probably feel  totally like I've accomplished something  today when in fact I haven't the machine  hasn't paid off the machine has given me  a medal all the machine does is  essentially you know massage my ego and  say gee you've got good reaction time  you can beat me now try again on the  next level welcome to the rebellion wait  no I love science fiction because you do  anything you want  it's boundless there's there's no form  there's no structure and that's what I  love about it so much please save the  oasis  you